hey guys how's it going it's justine
welcome back to my kitchen and i'm so
excited because today we
are continuing with the halloween theme
and today we are making
wait for it are you ready all right
murder
muffins first things first we're gonna
make the murder muffins they are going
to be like a red velvet cream cheese
something or other i'm not really sure i
found a nice recipe online i looked up
murder muffins and weird and
there wasn't anything let's get all of
our ingredients out and start blending
this and making it because the muffin
texture
is definitely not blender friendly
okay i tried to prep everything i tried
i tried to prep it all
[Applause]
one and one-fourth cups all-purpose
flour the purpose
is for all one
[Music]
thumb of flour 3 4 cup sugar put a
little more
baking powder and salt
i think i messed something up already
like i just freaking started
too oh shoot that's not accurate
all right we're going to whisk this
together not with a whisk
wow then whisk in the buttermilk cocoa
and food coloring oil
in a separate bowl
i don't have buttermilk either does that
matter it's on the menu
i mean recipe it's on the recipe that's
expired i'm just gonna use regular milk
don't tell anybody that's a very small
bowl i think i probably should
get a bigger one but i'm not going to oh
no i need cream cheese and it's not
softened
cocoa get away from me you freaking fly
making me very upset
i live in a barn would be great if you
really did just have a horse in here one
day
i we could rent it probably for like 800
bucks get away from my meal
get here the microphone he's so loud
put that in here okay food coloring
oil and egg that's just very lit that's
a lot actually
get away from me fly you're ruining my
meal
don't go in the cocoa oh my god he just
went in the sticks
guys why is this happening to me
i'm my body's not working today
half cup oil
these are measuring cups for people who
really can't measure because it
legit has every single possible
measurement
let's whisk this up whisk it good oh no
not this again oh god
[Music]
what next now i gotta mix this
wet in with the dry
look at that i'll promise you
i will treat you well
all right so i was supposed to beat the
cream cheese in the remaining 1 4 cup of
sugar in a small bowl
i did not save the sugar i guess just
dump a little sugar in here
like why is it does it even matter no it
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't
this is clearly not a very health
conscious meal or a snack
we need four ounces of this
which i think is probably like this much
i don't know
i gotta fold this cream cheese mixture
into this
i hate folding not into that
i hate baking i hate baking like i like
it but like i hate it i love it it's the
love hate
the love hate relationship that we have
hey can i
can i use your arms could you hold my
bowl yes
with sugar everywhere wow
yeah okay thank you now the next step is
to fold in our mixture
in here because you kind of wanted to
have a little bit of like cream cheese
stripes but i'm not sure if this is
going to work very well so
i'm not supposed to do it like this
either so
i'm already doing it wrong this is
folding
oh god i'm not doing it right
no it's too fast very slimy
super slimy let's get a little folding
action
yep looks folded to me then we're gonna
line our cupcake tin
with some black liners because it's very
festive
for the holiday season black cupcake
liners which you can get on amazon
it's a really new website just came out
i'd recommend filling up about three
fourths of a way
so you know like a nice scoop or two
all right here they are our lovely
murder muffins are ready for the oven so
let's pop those in and then we'll get
the icing ready
alexa set a timer for 17 minutes
17 minutes starting now yes
oh i'm so excited about these look at
these things they are so
great they're little edible knives and
you guys know what i like
i love knives so we're gonna do is we're
gonna use this it's cream cheese whipped
frosting and this actually looks really
good so we're gonna use this
for our icing i thought since we're
going with a red velvet theme we can put
some crumbly little cream cheese
oreos on it because why not where's my
blood where's my blood
oh god my blood we're gonna use gel
writing icing for blood these look
incredible
[Applause]
[Music]
so let this cool off and then it's time
to decorate
oh my god is this good you wanna lick
yeah
probably i don't want to lick it it is
good though i don't like that this isn't
white though
just kidding we're gonna be using this
whipped frosting
because it's a nice bright white just
what i was going for
and let's start decorating because i'm
super excited about this
this whipped topping is so great i just
started using this
so we're just going to ice these like
basic cupcakes
just a real nice little you know do
whatever you want i don't care
oh god i swear to god like these
things
this i did not mean to do this like i'm
actually trying and i think that's the
problem is when i try hard to do things
like i start failing god i'm so stupid
oh man no i'm not another pair of
scissors
okay i'm gonna try really hard this time
like this is not even a joke
come out of here once one thing goes
wrong then i just start getting really
upset
yeah i mean this is kind of boring but i
have to ice them so
[Music]
these are so cool i'm super excited
about this
i wonder what they taste like
is it edible oh god i think i cracked
something
now i'm not sure if this is going to
work or how this is going to work but
i'm going to
hope this is gel this isn't jello and a
very upset it's not gel
okay this one's gel
dexter was here god i missed extra that
was such a great show
i'll hollow this out real good alexa
cancel
[Music]
so we're gonna put a little of this in
nope no crime scene here officer
nothing to see here move along time to
dispose of the murder weapon
[Music]
there's no crime here there's no crime
here there's no crying mirror
i've been watching way too much crying
dramas
there we go wow these look so cool oh we
gotta add some of our little
oreos to them
here we go so this is dirt because they
tried to hide the murder weapon oj
and then they couldn't hide it oj and
then they actually did because they
never found the burger weapon but where
was the bag
like there's literally no one else that
could have done it like oj freaking did
it and of course if you pay like 50
million
in lawyer fees yeah better if we can get
[Music]
[Applause]
off
wait what i'm most excited about is
cutting open
this we gotta get the murder weapon it's
been hidden
and we need to cut it out could this
potentially be it
[Music]
oh yeah check that out that's something
something doesn't taste right it's just
coming down to see if there's anything
edible
yeah i mean these are okay they're cute
yeah right
it's okay i think that was something
yeah i think i messed something up why
are you so chunky
oh well it's fine it's okay it's just
chunky yeah it's just okay
all right guys thank you so much for
watching hope you guys enjoyed me making
these murder
muffins these are super cute i'll also
put a link in the description where you
guys can get these little knives at
i plan on recreating these for halloween
party that i'm having hopefully whatever
i did wrong for these ones i'll do right
for the party because i really want my
guests to feel
very happy about eating these i'll see
you guys in my next video
bye happy almost halloween
okay cool that's it cut and unseen
[Music]
you